[Music]
in bad parenting news [ __ ] I hope I'm
never in these article me too I'm a boy
submitted by mystery a dad was arrested
after admitting to locking his disabled
son you know in wooden cages for decades
[Laughter]
[Music]
for what wow what have you done to take
a [ __ ] just bouncing on the wood enjoy
yourself though I mean what happened was
it like a tree house that went wrong it
was too proud to say that he failed his
light yeah he started messing up the
tree house and then he just kept
building around it and he's like I'm not
gonna admit to anyone that I [ __ ] up
this tree house I'm just gonna yeah I
can't I can't justify the I can't
believe you put him in a wooden cage
that's right it's a wooden cage it's
great huh it's a good woody game yeah
I'm a great carpenter thank you
send me the jail for being awesome yeah
so there's six leaves in Japan boy you
never thought of that
I want people here we have here
something about Japanese parents putting
their disabled kids and some [ __ ]
shed type it was the other one remember
uh it was similar to this yeah it was
that the parents put their kid in a
maybe a garage or a room or something
they put him in a house that's terrible
shed or something but like they would
never like it was just locked out he was
locked up yeah so this dude the 73 year
old father allegedly locked up his son
went since he was 16
he's now 42 years old holy 26 no why
would you want to take care of a kid for
that long you have no choice
he's been Sabol oh that's right I keep
my thing he's a normal kid oh yeah he's
disabled and he's saying that he he has
been keeping him in that cage since he
was 16 because around that time he
became very violent oh oh [ __ ]
thought of it that way yeah does it say
what a disability was is it a mental
disability it just says um yeah mental
mental disability you know when a
mentally disabled kid attacks you it is
pretty weird
like you don't know what to do you see
it's out to you I've mentioned this
story before but he didn't attack me but
he was cutting towards me yeah and then
he grabbed him because I in that moment
I was thinking okay either I'm gonna
[ __ ] up this at the time this is the
terminology I use [ __ ] kid yeah
or I'm be the kid that got beat up by a
[ __ ] kid either way I lose you know
what it means so I was such a weird
situation I was like I'm either gonna
get made fun of for the rest of my life
or I'm gonna make fun for the rest my
life you can't even run away cause you'd
be the guy that's ran away exactly it's
the worst [ __ ] situation ever there's
nothing exactly so socially I'll spot
yeah so he sat down like oh and then
luckily dude ran out it was the the not
picked up the kid oh stop because he was
like raging at me I remember the hallway
and everything of what it looked like I
was I logic him out of the bathroom and
I saw this kid beeline it towards me yep
damn I wonder if those one of those
times were like you could like try to
camouflage into the wall natural animal
defense mechanisms my [ __ ] on herself
I'll play dead like what do you do like
till this day I don't know what I mean
what was going through that kid's mind
like he might have just been trying to
hug you dude no that [ __ ] was rageface
dude it wasn't one of them might be the
only face it was like like something
pissed him off and he was gonna attack
anything close to him and it was me you
were just coming out of the bath you had
time to think like I can't hit the dude
I can't run away I can't yeah when
you're brave go take it goes though like
it fires off it's like oh [ __ ] goes into
slow motion [ __ ] you yeah
oh I'm gonna be the guys to be made fun
of and these are the five different ways
it's like have you ever been in
like so like when I was in a car
accident - I remember like my the car
spun like four times or some sheet flew
into a ditch I can't remember what I was
thinking about and that was probably
only like two seconds like I'm dead like
I'm not gonna see my parents anymore
like my whole life is [ __ ] yes yeah
but this dude here so apparently the
cage was slightly bigger than a coffin
oh my god a Japanese car torture that
three foot high King nah [ __ ] the dad
he's a [ __ ] liar yeah so because of
that when they found him his sons back
was bent and he was nearly blind due to
an infection from the filthy conditions
yeah that's not just for me being
violent you didn't have any
life-threatening conditions or or an
illness but he couldn't stand up really
he can't use his legs okay here's a
small cage yeah I didn't grow no bigger
than a coffin I mean a little bit bigger
than coffee yeah that's crazy it's
really it's a really small confined
space what a [ __ ] bag dude I hope that
guy goes to hell yeah I think he
probably like attacked him once and then
he was like I'm gonna punish you and
then like just do it forever
he wasn't even well the way they worded
this it was in a cage inside a hut next
to his house so it wasn't even in the
same hole is there a picture of the man
no I don't have any I want to see the
dude that did it yeah so he was 73 so I
feel like I feel like we don't have many
options of what Japanese people live to
those 300 so he still has a long way to
go so they should [ __ ] him up yeah I
hope he gets tortured I really do did
they say how they found the kid or like
what happened oh yeah that's a good yeah
so apparently he finally bit through one
of the wooden bars so he had contacted a
city official about nursing care for his
wife and then that's when he admitted
about the whole son thing he just came
out I'm pretty sure he was just like
[ __ ] like I can't take care of my wife
anymore I'm gonna need help so they're
gonna see this so I might as well just
home yeah I bet you I bet you because
obviously the dude's real dumb he
probably called about his wife and he's
like oh if they can take care of my wife
he's like by the way I got this other
thing what can you do about this and he
probably accidentally just like admitted
it yeah he's done
yeah but that's like you pretty much
said it so he knew what he was doing was
wrong yeah and it was so sad too but
they're saying that when they officials
visited the home and they found him that
he was sitting on a on a pee pad for pet
inside of the cage are you kidding me
but at least the hut had an AC unit so
weird level of thought you know what I
mean yeah are you gonna put him in a
cage let her [ __ ] on himself but you
can't be hot but I mean I guess he was
exposed from the waist down
and the father says that he would bathe
his son every other day and feed him
every other day every other day damn
that's uh I'll be pissed if I only got
to eat once every 48 hours piss oh I
would look good though I would bite it
get you on that on the captive wife - no
man I can't I can't go that long I get
hangry y'all don't get hangry i get
hangry well you made a love for a tiny
little package though you had like five
buckles and some rice and [ __ ] i was
like god damn really oh I felt like it
wasn't even that much but you must [ __ ]
a crap-ton then huh you must hit a crap
time no you looked at me for an answer
like you must [ __ ] a lot you should and
I know like the thinnest usually like
the thinnest people that eat a lot be
really fast it just goes in and out in
and out like a [ __ ] factory I'll eat
this much but I'll put this little ru
scenaries I don't know where it goes do
you poop like several times throughout
the day it goes right here it doesn't
leave oh wait do you move like more than
once a day just like I poop every day
but it doesn't equate to the amount that
I'm eating which is annoying hmm you
know I'm saying it's like I went
somewhere I gave them $20 per change and
they only gave me $5 back yeah it's very
upsetting no we know someone that eats a
[ __ ] ton and she can't poop oh yeah
that's so real so fit and so thin
how does that work that just makes no
sense some people are just blessed that
way man huh
I'm definitely not I shake good you
should so much the poop pics out of the
water yes he always wants to show me
cause he's so proud of it or something
does he take pictures one time I had
food poisoning so I was throwing up like
crazy for three days straight I couldn't
really eat anything and then finally
when I could stomach something I was
eating only saltine crackers and bananas
and then so my first solid poop it was a
albino poop that was like it was all
white it was all white it was like 14
inches long and I'm like wow what a
white poop mean that's how clean that
[ __ ] was oh I've read a lot of poop
articles like what does this mean I've
never seen it was all white and I just
the whole banana the only time I've seen
white poop is one like when a dog just
eats a bunch of bones and they'll
examine like white poop it was white it
was mind-blowing
well this quick google search says that
white poop is present when the liver
does not release enough bile salts into
your stool so did I throw up throw it
all up and ran out of bile salt yeah I
said that this may occur due to bile
duct blockages gall stones or liver
problems really bad I have food
poisoning I gained a pound off that shoe
this is whack ha I don't know you don't
[ __ ] your brains out you know what I
think cuz like I had food poison was - I
didn't eat anything right and then I
just the only thing I ate that day was
like some noodle soup and then I gained
a pound like it literally I was so
pissed so [ __ ] mad
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]